hey guys Pete here are you ready to take
a closer look at the west-world 2
trailer it's what I've been doing for
the last day or so now and there's a ton
of stuff to look at yesterday I posted
my initial Westworld season 2 trailer
breakdown and today we're gonna look at
it closer because there's a bunch of
details that you might miss there's an
alternative version of it that is only
slightly different but the added footage
is pretty interesting that was on the
discover West world site and then there
was another really cool new site that
fans found from code that was hidden in
the trailer that we saw during the Super
Bowl
it has hidden easter eggs and it
introduces a brand new character which
we also see in that alternative version
of the trailer it's a lot of stuff and
it's great to see that West world's
picking up right where it left off as
far as the off-screen stuff that makes
this show so much fun to follow in
between episodes let's talk about the
alternate version of the trailer first
redditor gunslinger 1969 posted on
reddit that he noticed there was some
differences in the trailer that's on
discover West's world and he put that
trailer there where you can watch it as
mentioned it's almost exactly the same
except for there's four little shots
that sneak in to what we already saw the
first one is Maeve she's bleeding
there's someone standing over her to me
it looks like Clementine but it could
literally be anybody this could be at
any time in the past or present because
there's really no way to know
I mentioned the Civil War scene in the
trailer in my last breakdown and there's
another shot of these guys but in this
one we see three other hosts hanging
from trees I really can't see anything
else here they give us an indication
that who these might be or if they're
important they're probably not but it
goes along with what we saw in the
longer version of the trailer then we
see a shot of the church where we saw
Dolores find out about being Wyatt and
the maze and everything else we see
someone from the ghost nation is what it
looks like from behind walking up and
I'm kind of excited about this because
if
remember in season one they touched on
this in the one episode where maid was
starting to figure out what was going on
they talked about the natives and their
belief systems in the way that they
believed and basically the parks staff
as being higher powers or whatever you
want to call them their gods and then it
kind of just trailed away from that so
hopefully we'll see more of that I mean
there we have the the ghost nation which
is out there killing hosts beyond you
know the regular part of the park so
there have an autonomous kind of
existence and the natives you know
they're there but we haven't really
learned that much about them so it'd be
cool to learn more about it after that
shot we see a man who is bending over
another character who we have no idea
who it is they have blood on their hands
so as they're touching his face you see
the blood no idea who it is no idea
who's laying beneath him but interesting
for sure and then the last sequence that
gives us a couple shots of who turns out
to be James Delos now I'll get into this
a little bit more because it has to do
with the website that was found but
according to this website James Delos is
the guy who at least from the corporate
side you know obviously dr. Ford did but
dr. Ford did with Arnold but he is the
person who is regarded as the founder of
the parks in the short scenes that we
see we see him looking in a mirror with
a bloody face this could be from the
first uprising and then there is another
shot which to me looks like Ed Harris
made to look slightly younger than he is
now looking and what appears to be James
Delos in his office he sort of smashes
something there this could be somebody
else this is not for sure but again it's
a pretty neat thing to hide in there as
mentioned there is a new website it's
called Delos destinations calm the
redditor a skin one posted a really cool
post on Reddit he noticed the sequence
that flashes on the screen in the
background he describes it as a binary
and says it decodes to a number sequence
which is 52 89 126 34 and that takes you
to the
website there's two big takeaways from
this new website one is it lists six
parks although there's no indication of
what the other ones are obviously we've
seen samurai or Shogun world teased but
you can see the website is kind of
broken and there are six parks none of
them are available right now and that's
mostly due to what's going on after the
long journey in tonight now if you watch
the original movie you know there was
three parks there so this means we have
twice as many there's also a future
world which was the sequel to West World
the movie there has been a lot of talk
since the end of last season about
fleshing out some of these other parks
but I don't know where guaranteed to see
much more than that they exist at this
point but you have to imagine that they
will do a callback to the original and
there'll be a Roman world a medieval
world and that still leaves three more
that are up for speculation at this
point when you click on the investors
tab of that website you get this Delos
is more than a company page and we learn
about the founder James Delos starts out
saying decades ago a man had an idea as
old as human ambition itself that the
only limit to progress is imagination
the ability to see a better world
Nellis Incorporated was formed from that
goal and nothing else because James had
nothing else he used to joke that where
he grew up having dreams was like
fighting gravity but he never lost faith
that his dream could take off and now
Delos is more than a name it's a legacy
so we will inevitably learn more about
this character to me it seems like it
would just be we'll see how the
corporate side of things came to
integrate with dr. Ford's vision we're
not 100% sure Lord's gonna come back
there's quite a lot of people who think
that he will but nothing that we can say
for sure that's evidence that that will
happen but given that the man in black
looks to be younger if that is him in
that scene and that we know that Jimmy
Simpson is also coming back
to reprise his younger version much
younger version this could lead to the
interesting side story of how Delos got
involved and just more about how the man
in black evolved into what he is beyond
that a couple of things Jonathan Nolan
who is one of the show runners and
creators of the show gave an interview
to Entertainment Weekly where he
discussed the ad in yesterday's video I
asked about what you guys thought might
be specific to the trailer because
Entertainment Weekly had said that that
there were certain things that were only
shot for the thing and a lot of people
thought it was the mave sequence which I
tended to agree with but Jonathan Nolan
tells us that that's not the case the
only thing that was shot exclusively for
this trailer was this shot of Dolores at
the end where she talks directly to the
camera the rest is actually all pulled
from the season itself but the way that
the interview describes it they put some
additional production into that Maeve
scene to make it more of a Super Bowl ad
kind of thing rather than just what it
looks like in the regular show so you
guys were kind of right but at the same
time that wasn't what they were alluding
to whenever they had their first
interview the new Jonathan Nolan
interviews in Entertainment Weekly and
it's worth a read he talks about how
they went for this and he actually
mentions that this is not a trailer this
is a Superbowl ad that they'll release a
proper trailer coming up before the
season but you know he had this idea he
wanted to make it into this thing and I
think they really pulled it off he talks
about how him and his co-creator / wife
Lisa joy had the composure
Ramin the Jawad ii reimagined kanye west
songs a lot of people had posted that
that it was runaway he talks about that
and what he thought why he wanted to do
that and he mentions that his dad was an
advertising guy as a kid so he always
wanted to make a commercial and this was
a hell of a chance to do it
they also touch on the fact that
benbarnes shows up as Logan and that
Lewis
Herthum shows up as Peter Abernathy he
talks about how we see them both in this
trailer
the benbarnes thing is a little bit cool
that I didn't realize when I watched it
at first that I thought he was outside
of the park but it's been pointed out
that they are all frozen everyone around
him is frozen except for him and the
person that's accompanying him the woman
right next to him so this is likely in
the decompression area before you go
back out into the real world and these
are all hosts that are around him so
that alludes to more to his story and
how he moves forward with what he's
doing and how William Mann and black
does whatever he did another thing I saw
online was that we see Bernard he's
played by Jeffrey Wright with that
faceless host coming up behind him I
mentioned that the last scene we saw was
him getting thrown into that device
where they produced the hosts if you
look at the two scenes though the
clothing is not the same it doesn't look
like it I mean the first ones dark so
maybe it's just the way the lighting is
but it looks like the guys wearing a
light coat like a light gray or light
blue coat that's in the second shot
whereas in the first one it looks like
Bernard is wearing something dark so
that could be him and the host attacking
that person like he could be using the
host to attack that person not really
sure they're also and these came from
Kim rumf Rose host on the insider comm I
noticed this yesterday when I was
zooming in that they're not all animals
down at the bottom that they're actually
people when you look over this long shot
where we saw Bernard and Stubbs so this
could be from directly after that event
where we saw the host attacking and we
saw the man in black get shot hidden
inside the del Oeste nation site was
also a bunch of images of this guide
book for new Delos employees and there's
also some handwriting scratched in on it
like written on top of it this could be
referring to Elsie and her trying to get
information out or it could just be you
know could just go along with the stuff
that we saw on the discover West world
site in the chat bot at the
in the last season there's also other
things that we saw last season like this
overview of the Mesa complex the
flowchart of Dolores's behavior that you
know all that stuff was hidden on the
website last year and I had it in some
of my videos that came out towards the
end of the season but yeah so it's just
really cool to see that they're building
this stuff outside of the show to keep
us all interested in between and that is
most of the interesting stuff I've been
able to come up with make sure you tell
me in the comments about anything you
noticed that you think I missed or these
other people on reddit missed make sure
you like the video if you enjoyed it
feel free to let me know about your
ideas for future videos on the run-up to
season 2 which will be starting on April
22nd put that in the comments and then
any other ideas that you have make sure
you subscribe to my channel I plan on
doing Westworld it's got last year I was
one of the few people who actually got
into it and now everybody's doing it so
hopefully some of you guys will stick
with a fan who's been here since the
beginning if you do subscribe you'll
want to set up notifications so you know
when the new videos come out you follow
me on social media and get in touch with
me over there and definitely think about
checking out my patreon account and what
we're doing there because that's the
fastest way to stay in touch with me and
have influence on where the channel goes
in the future that's it for now thanks
for watching guys I'll talk to you soon
you
you